well our culture is the most popular
pastime as we know is complaining
especially about stress you know the
idea of stress as we know it today
wasn't invented in the english language
until the 1930s before that it's fair to
say that nobody ever complained about
their stress because the concept didn't
really exist that's not to say that
people didn't feel stressed or didn't
lead stressful lives it's just to say
that they that they simply lived those
lives and dealt with the strain without
feeling the need to put a label on it
and talk about it incessantly
these days though by most measures we
have easier lives we love nothing more
than to talk about our difficulties
we're so burned out
we have so much anxiety so much stress
everything is so hard and we need to
talk about this to our friends our
families to strangers on the internet to
counselors and therapists i mean we've
got armies of people we've set up
to just complain to them about how hard
our lives are
we have to vomit our feelings of being
overburdened onto everyone
everywhere all the time this is without
question the modern world's favorite
hobby
now our second favorite hobby is to come
up with trendy new labels for common
human experiences so we like to take
things that people have always done
and or always felt and always said and
invent a term to describe so that we can
pretend that this universal experience
is somehow novel
so for example
um recently i came across the term
flexitarian to describe people who eat
both vegetables and meat
this is a diet strategy shared by 99 of
the human civilization since the dawn of
civilization but now the flexitarian can
pretend that he's reinvented the wheel
by giving this exceedingly normal thing
a brand new name
in fact i'm surprised we haven't come up
with a new name four wheels so that we
can pretend we actually did reinvent
them
maybe we'll get around to that
eventually as we seem to specialize in
the art of inventing things that were
already invented but what happens when
these two popular pastimes are combined
what if we could whine about our
stressful lives while also inventing a
new label for something people have
always done
what if we could do both that would be
the modern
uh dream that's the holy grail
and that's what brings us to the hot new
trend called quiet quitting
now the media tells us that quiet
quitting is a revolutionary concept
quickly gaining traction in society and
especially in the workplace the
headlines are full of references to this
practice here's some samples of the
headlines quiet quitting is a trend
taking over tick tock and your workplace
everyone is talking about quiet quitting
but is it a good idea
three millennials on their experience of
quiet quitting
what is quiet quitting and why are
employees doing it and explainer
the washington post provides more
details it says quietquitting is taking
social media by storm but you might not
have noticed the term is a bit of a
misnomer because quiet quitters aren't
walking away from their jobs instead
they're renouncing hustle culture
quitting the idea of going above and
beyond at work as tick-tock user zade
lepin
oh that's what he did there set in a
july post that has uh amassed more than
three million views and helped
popularize the phrase the trend is
resonating strongly with those gen z and
millennial workers fighting to rewrite
the rules of the workplace signs of
quiet quitting look like classic
indicators of diminished motivation and
low engagement according to joe grasso
senior
director of workplace transformation at
lyra health
that might be decreased productivity or
withdrawing from the team limiting
communication and interaction to only
what's required graso said
it could manifest as employee cynicism
or apathy about work or staying silent
rather than sharing input
now the article goes on to explain that
quiet quitting is the result of quote
unprecedented employee burnout
people are feeling more burned out and
overworked than ever before allegedly
this has led to the quiet quitting trend
wherein employees in defiance of
something called hustle culture decide
to go to work but put in less effort
they'll do only the bare minimum and no
more
they'll work but they won't work hard
as mentioned this is a major type of
conversation on tick tock especially
where people are too burned out to do
their jobs
but not too burned out to record tick
tock videos talking about how burned out
they are so here's one viral tick tock
video uh giving more details about this
revolutionary new concept
everybody's talking about quiet quitting
and how it's the new negative talent
crisis
i think it's a good thing
the youngest generations at work are
rejecting the idea of hustle culture or
framing your entire life around some
dream job
they're rejecting putting their mental
health below their performance goals
with quiet quitting you're doing what
you're paid for and not more and it's
about setting boundaries around what
you're willing to do
if the inflation rate is eight and a
half percent and you get a one percent
raise
what do employers expect
i see this as a healthy evolution that
can actually equalize the employee
employer relationship more
do you think quiet quitting is a good
thing
let me know
okay
so a few points here
first of all
doing the bare minimum at work is not
some unique quirky new approach to life
we don't need a label for it
we already had a label it's called lazy
and lazy people have always existed
in fact they made a movie called office
space over 20 years ago about exactly
this idea i think this is my second
office space references many shows uh
the protagonist feels drained by his
soul-sucking office job and decides to
stop trying and hilarity ensues but
office space didn't invent anything
either in fact what makes the movie
funny is that it's relatable
everybody knows what it's like to be fed
up with your job you know and and to be
fed up with other various mundane
aspects of your life everybody has
fantasized about adopting and i don't
give a damn attitude
everyone is especially fantasized about
smashing office appliances with a
baseball bat as they do in that film the
point is that millennials in gen z
aren't sparking a revolution here
they're experiencing laziness
the only difference is that they're
narcissistic enough to think they
invented it
second um if if if you want to do the
bare minimum
that's fine okay
that's uh that's mediocrity
and if you want to live a mediocre life
you're welcome to it
many people before you have chosen that
path and many people after you will do
the same that's why it's mediocrity
just just don't pretend that you're
putting in less of an effort at your job
so that you can invest more of your time
into more enriching pursuits and
passions now that may be what a very
small fraction of the quiet quitters do
but it's not how it works for the vast
majority
as we discussed last week most people
who give themselves more free time end
up spending all of that extra spare time
staring at their phones or watching
netflix
now if you're actually going to
take all the free time take all the
extra energy you have now because you
are quiet quitting and go climb mount
everest
or start a side business or even like
take painting classes or something then
then okay
you are reinvesting your time and energy
into another uh pursuit that to you is
more worthwhile but that is just simply
not what most people do or are going to
do and we should be honest about that
and you should be honest with yourself
and if you're doing the bare minimum at
work refusing to go above and beyond and
not pursuing anything else notable with
your life
then you will be unsuccessful and again
mediocre that's who you're going to be
that's what your life is going to be
you will not flourish financially or in
any other way
you're going to leave little mark on the
world you'll achieve nothing of note
that is going to be your life
now the luxury of the modern world does
provide people with the unprecedented
option of coasting by on the bare
minimum if they want expending very
little energy
this was not a lifestyle available to
most people for most of history now it
is available
you can take advantage of that
opportunity and you can if you want but
it does come with a price nothing is
free
even laziness is not free especially
laziness is not free
not in this life
being lazy will extract a payment from
you whether you like it or not and what
you are giving up in exchange for ease
of life is any chance of doing anything
notable interesting or great with your
life
because the notable interesting and
great things are done by people who give
more of themselves than is required
the great lives are led by those who
look for ways to give more not less
this is also true just just you know in
the microcosm of the workplace
for the most part the people who succeed
okay are the ones who are giving giving
more so you're just doing exactly what
you need to the guy next to you is doing
a lot more than he needs to he's
probably gonna be more successful than
you
and then when he is you're gonna whine
about it and say oh it's not fair this
isn't fair
actually it's totally fair
now it's possible there could be someone
who's awarded with success even though
they didn't earn it and you did these
that kind of unfairness really does
happen
but but probably that's not the case
probably that's a story you're telling
yourself to make yourself feel better
probably that person earned it
and you didn't
and in general the great people are the
ones who do hard things not the ones who
avoid hard things that's a fact of life
it will never change
so all i'm asking
you to be a quiet quitter fine
don't come around later complaining
about your lack of success don't become
envious of the people more successful to
you you wanted to quiet quit okay you
wanted to put in less effort you aimed
low and you got what you wanted
you have no right to resent people who
aimed higher than you
third and final point related to the
first two points
i am not suggesting that you should stay
forever in a job you hate pouring
yourself into it year after miserable
year if you if you hate your job and you
feel unfulfilled by it
if you feel that it's not making use of
your talents if you think it's a dead
end etc then go chase something better
if if you just don't want to work at all
then you're a lazy overgrown child and
as long as you maintain that attitude
you're destined as previously discussed
to be a mediocre failure and a disgrace
and an embarrassment to your family and
everyone who knows you but if you're
willing to work and yet you feel that
your work right now is wasted or futile
or pointless
then go and pursue a new opportunity and
yeah you can make a scale i can't do
that i can't do it for all these right
you can make excuses all you want i
can't do it it's a risk if i do that if
i do it it won't work out if i gotta get
this i have a family
those are those are excuses and i mean
they might even be valid
but once again the people who do great
things are not focused on the excuses or
they act in spite of them
staying at your job and trying to do the
bare minimum is the coward's way out
that's what the guy in office space
discovered by the end of the film he had
left the office world completely found
happiness as a construction worker
he found work that was meaningful to him
and that's what you should do
because that's professional success
right there isn't a certain salary you
have to reach in order to be successful
professionally what matters is whether
you're doing work that is meaningful to
you
and which utilizes your talents skills
and efforts
that's success
and it's a lot better than being a lazy
bum
also known as a quiet quitter
and that's why quiet quitting
as a concept and especially also just as
a label
is cancelled well before you go uh hit
the subscribe button and ring the bell
and while you're at it if you want to go
watch or listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated